you say that you're going to do
everything that you can to reduce the
impact that high gas prices have on
americans
we're asking other countries to think
about maybe pumping more oil why not
just do it here
well to be very clear federal policies
are not
uh limiting the supplies of oil and gas
to the co let me finish to the con let
me finish an executive order
halted new oil gas let me let me give
you let me give you the facts here and i
know that can be inconvenient but i
think they're important in this moment
there are nine thousand approved
drilling permits that are not being used
so the suggestion that we are not
allowing companies to drill is
inaccurate
shin saki blowing up on our very own
peter ducey and getting a little
defensive over exploding gas prices the
cost of a gallon is now over four
dollars nationally and the president's
plan to deal with it is to kiss up to
dictators instead of producing more oil
here at home
biden advisors are toying with a
possible trip to saudi arabia to beg
beg for more energy production
u.s officials are holding rare
face-to-face meetings
with venezuela
and a new nuclear deal with iran could
be wrapped up at any moment
the white house also saying no decision
has been made on banning importing
russian oil
and nikki haley unloading on the biden
administration for funding putin's war
machine watch
we need to start standing up why are we
even
ho-humming around the fact that we're
still taking russian oil why are we
doing that why would we take money from
from evil dictators you never sleep with
the devil because then the devil owns
you the europeans are finding that out
right now we need to be smarter than
that
we'll be really smart did we just open
up anwar in alaska boom case closed
you were mentioning the iran deal that's
now on the ropes because
you know russia's now saying hey hey you
need us on this and they want oil from
the iranians where's that money go well
put it this way with russia's help we
might be able to get the iran deal we
never wanted so i so and gary kasparov
said it perfectly who knows vladimir
putin was exiled because of him he said
wait a second what do you think vladimir
putin thinks
this is the country that's helping us
out is uh indirectly or directly
targeting nuclear power plants in the
ukraine while threatening nuclear war on
us if we do x y and z now we need sergey
lavrov to go in there and convince iran
to act as irresponsible as they are with
nuclear weapons should they get them so
to cut a deal that nobody want and uh
dan i know you know this senator ben
cardin voted against the 2015 deal
senator schumer voted against the deal
center menendez voted against the deal
that's the 215 deal when you had no when
you had to go into military bait you
were not allowed on military bases do
snap inspections were they able to use
some of the money from their oil to fund
tara real quick to close this out we're
about to do a worse deal and the worst
thing is nobody knows anything about it
they're about to do something behind
closed door that's going to affect world
peace especially in the middle east and
because we put all those sanctions on
iran we got the abrahamic courts because
people said i'll take israel and saudi
arabia's side over that evil regime and
so that's all gone the saudi kings they
don't want this iran deal but biden tell
us how this is going to look dana perino
air force one touches down in riyadh and
he walks out under the tarmac and he
greets the king and the king just
are americans gonna go for something
like that right now
with aviators on yeah with the aviators
um i will forever make sure that it's
clear that we were seeing record gas
prices before
russia invaded ukraine okay so number
one when you're going to talk about
energy policy in the united states start
there and then unfortunately it looks
like it is going to get worse you have a
situation now where you have basically
we're willing to look past all the human
rights violations
in saudi or venezuela we're okay with
the fact that iran says that they want
to destroy israel but now we're going to
go and give them this deal and also
maybe take their oil and
i understand that there might be needs
to figure out a way to get more oil into
the system if russia's going to be cut
out i get that but i also think that the
administration continues to say we have
to transition to green energy but they
just are not sober minded enough to say
we need to do lots of things all at once
there's going to be a shift if they
don't announce some sort of a shift
no one is going to ever say that they
did it them going to saudi and iran is
not the shift that we're talking about
so you can you can say that we as a
nation want to get to a cleaner greener
energy future it's going to take some
time and tell the squad to sit down
while you explain it and then you walk
them through and you say i'm going to
put a ton of money into innovation in
the meantime we are going to go to visit
texas and we're going to pennsylvania
we're going to go to northern california
we're going to go to wyoming montana all
the places where the united states has
energy we
produce energy in a much more
environmentally friendly way than any
other country and the squad needs to
hear about that too i think they're so
worried about the left and their climate
goals and the ipcc put out another
report today about the climate we have
to worry about the climate right now
there are people worried about actual
survival of the western world yeah
that's what we need to think about
exactly what's it going to look like
memorial day weekend people starting to
hit the road fill up the tank take the
kids on a trip and it's 450 a gallon
that's a hundred dollars to fill up
your tank how how do the democrats
survive politically
well that would be hard for anybody i
think it could be higher than 450. we
ought to be we ought to be happy if it's
450 yeah memorial day if you look at
if you look at where we are look where
we are right now
few facts dana i agree with a lot of
what she said i disagree with a little
bit of it but i agree wholeheartedly
that
build nuclear frack and drill have to be
part of the the lexicon for any energy
reform any climate change reform bills
just like they're they're crazies on the
republican side they're though unstable
thinkers on the republican side they're
unstable democratic thinkers as well and
we've got to share share with them all
two prior to covet prior to cobit our
barrels per day usage in america was a
hundred million plus barrels as much as
103 million barrels a day we're now down
as of 2021 we were at 96.2 million
barrels a day so as demand gets back up
to where we were before obviously prices
could go back up so dana to your point
about some of the record prices we went
down during copenhagen we're going to
find ourselves going back up
finally um
this energy thing i i i struggle like
you do with this brian and it's the
worst of of options
do we do we do we ask the saudis to
produce more
there are things that we're concerned
about there there's certainly positive
things or negative things do we go to
venezuela do we go to the iranians
i mean i don't know i'd rather go the
worst of those options to venezuela
because i think we can strike a simpler
deal but i'll leave that i'll leave that
to the diplomats but i got to tell you
eleven dollars a barrel versus dylan
with one of those three would've asked
voters in pennsylvania and texas and the
dakotas which one they which would they
like well let's hear from america's
greatest diplomat judge jeanine
would you well actually you fly to
caracas you're the only one on the table
who ran for office five times okay would
you ever fly to caracas and sorry and
negotiate with the venezuelans not a
chance no not a chance i don't want
their oil i don't want iran's oil i
don't want russian oil i want american
oil and you know the one person who made
the most sense today
was elon musk when elon musk called to
increase domestic oil output while
acknowledging that it's going to
negatively impact his energy car
business he said extraordinary times
demand extraordinary actions and it was
like drill baby drill that's all we've
got to do is drill and you know what
don't say it's so simplistic because we
did it and when we did it or the uh gas
was cheap and it was clean and then
biden came in and made a mess of all of
it and that's all i have to say you're
hooked on uh
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else